while my father was getting rid of
tanya's valentine i wish he'd been
around to get rid of mine
roses are red violets are blue
please go back to africa and take your
mother with you
happy valentine's day
another card like this and i might just
go to africa
what's wrong with you
i'm trying not to bump into joy again
school's only but so big you're bound to
run into her sometimes i just don't want
to blow it i don't know what my next
move is well did you get her a card no
then that's your next move
hey you can come with me i was gonna go
get one anyway for who
the girl on the bus she gave me one
yesterday and you didn't tell me i know
i go to bed early but you can still call
and wake me up when something this
important happens yeah well i wants to
tell you a person i broke up a fight
between her and her body you broke up a
fight
yeah she gave me this card dude this is
huge is it i i don't know
it's just a card a card is i'm yours for
the taking how in there do you have to
be before you get it
why is it that when it comes to me you
know so much about girls but you freak
out when one gives you a card
i guess it's kind of like not being able
to cut your own hair
before you ever buy a girl a gift the
first thing you got to do is buy her the
perfect car
that's too much you haven't even kissed
her yet
have you
um
how about this one
you know the deal i want you to be my
valentine
that's cool but it's more for a friend
than a girl
whoa cool
relatively speaking would you be my
valentine
this is perfect for tangy
no thanks
no for joy greg never fought being a
nerd i always wondered how that worked
out for me
come on
come on honey
bag when did you get this car no the
kind of like this one
dude
this card is two dollars and fifty cents
hey you gotta pay to play right
[Music]
quick give me my card
here
here this is for you thank you no no no
read when you get home okay
man that was close
what's this
oh ha ha very funny
chris
how could you
when i found out how caruso had been
teasing you i thought you'd appreciate a
real valentine from someone
obviously i was wrong nowadays you wish
all the teacher gave your kids were
called i didn't know it was yours
[Music]
you